and by the way why don't you tell them
what happened when you and your husband
met trump what did he do with melania
that's that's a good story it's really
an incredible i'll try to do this
somewhat quick version of it we go it
was the week of impeachment the yeah
there was 18 impeachment i was like
which one dude yeah the first the first
shaman the original and remember it
remember remember those two weeks where
everybody everyone in mainstream media
the walls are closing in trump is
freaking out
um
the whole thing so i heard i was at a
turning point usa thing in west palm i i
spoke and then then trump announced that
he was coming so they cleared out all
the so basically i ended up opening for
him and then for trump he spoke yeah
dude but it wasn't planned that way it
was just that he announced that he was
coming out of nowhere so then so i spoke
he speaks i had never heard him speak in
person before and first so already
something had moved with me that morning
because when he spoke and you see him
speak live and then you read the media
after you can really see the disconnect
so there's a beautiful moment in his
speech where he's talking about wind
power and he's like i know wind power
more than anybody and nobody knows more
about wind than me and the turbines
and he's going on and it's so obviously
a joke it's so obviously just a punk and
i turned to david and i said to him i
guarantee you politico is going to write
a headline or one that donald trump says
he knows more about when and of course
five minutes later the headline shows up
anyway uh we see junior there and we
become sort of friendly he says you want
to come to dinner with kimberly and i to
mar-a-lago tonight so obviously we said
yes we go in again this is the height of
impeachment we're in the you know
there's two rooms there we're in the
smaller rooms there's only about 20
people or so there's trump sitting there
with melania
and rudy giuliani and one or two other
people
and he has his shirt open really open no
tie first yeah so first off you never
see trump like this right his jacket's
kind of leaning back he looks relaxed
his hair looked relaxed like he's just
ha and he's laughing and having a blast
and i'm just you know we're not sitting
at the same table but i just kind of
have my you know i'm just looking right
anyway at the end of dinner junior says
hey you want to meet my dad so obviously
yeah i'd love to meet your dad so we
walk over and and the president's
sitting and he says dad i want you to
meet dave rubin um
and and he looks at me and he's
sitting so he looks up and he's like i
kind of recognize you i kind of and i
was like oh well i'm on tucker a lot or
maybe you see me outside he says oh yeah
yeah that must be it and then he turns
to david my husband and he goes well who
are you
and he goes well i'm his husband
and he goes husband husband
that's great you guys are gay he goes
melania can you believe it these two
guys are gay
he goes
he goes guys let me tell you something
you know what your only problem is
you're too handsome both of you guys are
too handsome yeah that's what he said
and then melania then uh she's kind of
points she's with a friend she's kind of
pointing at david so david walks around
the table to talk to melania and then
it's me junior and trump and then
somebody grabbed junior so now it's just
me and trump and this is also so it's
impeachment and it's also right when
bloomberg got in the race yeah so i had
this moment alone with trump i'm like i
gotta say something that says you know
something so i was like i was like mr
president i just got to tell you my
crazy theory and my theory is
that the machine wants biden because
it's just a vestige of the old thing but
they know he can't survive in the
debates because he's so bad so so
bloomberg is in basically as a decoy
which i really believe is what happened
they threw him in it was never real but
they needed because biden was still
leading they needed all the energy
remember those two debates with
bloomberg it was only about him biden
barely spoke because they knew he would
break down under under attacks
so i tell him this i said it's a
complete decoy bloomberg's not running
it's all about biden and he's he's like
this he's like you know
that's that's something that's something
and then he goes and this also really
changed me on trump he reaches across
the table and he puts his hand on
melania
like very gingerly softly puts his hand
on melania and he goes honey honey
listen to this and he said it lovingly
right and the the meme is that they hate
each other or she's a cat you know kept
she slapped whatever that one time they
played it a million times i'm telling
you he did it in the way a husband that
loves his wife would touch her hand and
then he called her honey so the way he
did that
so he has me repeat what i said to him
uh to her
and i say it and she kind of nods and
then he goes nah he just hates me
talking about bloomberg meaning that's
why he got it he just hates me but the
thing that moved me more than the the
gay thing or that silly story
is that he loves his wife it was very
obvious that i told him something
interesting and his first inclination
was to tell his wife what does that tell
you about the guy very interesting very
interesting yeah i've i've heard him a
few times at mar-a-lago and i got to
tell you
the guy could have been a comedian yeah
he's a stand-up he's a stand-up
because there's no cameras he gets up
and it's 90 minutes no script no nothing
any
half the time you're laughing with jokes
and obviously he's trolling i think he's
going to go all the time as the greatest
troll of all time i think he has the
gold medal for it i think he owes the
guinness book of world record for it i
don't think anyone's going to come close
to him as a troll he's in the league of
his own but what's so impressive about
the whole situation is the fact that
he's about to get impeached the second
time biden could potentially win and
he's just having a good time i'm telling
you
this guy shirt open like this there was
something it was just like he
that also was when i was just like all
of media it broke down a lot of things
for me that he loves his wife he didn't
care about gays that the media is just
so dishonest it wasn't just the wind
power article that i knew was gonna come
it was just he's freaking out you know
he's in his inner sanctum with his and
it was like no he isn't he's sitting
there laughing his ass off
they just lie about it they really they
really don't like this guy too much they
really don't like this guy too much
but here's here's going back to it
here's the thing
the bench is deep on the right the bench
is not deep on the left even if i ask
you right now who
you couldn't come up with five names on
the left booker not gonna happen no pete
beto who do you got no they'll make it
they'll make it bp that's the one that
they'll move on they'll make it be pete
yeah don't forget about gavin
is going to be there there's no question
is going to be there gamma's going to be
there no question do you have any stars
you're excited about outside of mansion
because he's not going to run
he's not going to run cinema's not going
to run and you don't think mansion would
run if mansion ran he would never get
the support from the left halsey gabbard
would never get the support from the
left so because you need to rally your
base right and who's the democratic base
right now it's a lot of the aoc crowd
the bernie crowd
but that's not who the true democratic
voter is like the the loudest people in
the room the ten percent on that side
just like the do you like do you like
tulsi i'm guessing you probably like
i mean i don't follow her well enough to
be like that's my girl yeah uh but yeah
i do like the fact that she challenges
the establishment yeah she's she's a
good woman we've become friendly she's a
good woman
i can't i i mean i say this to her
privately all the time but it's like how
are you a democrat still it just doesn't
make sense
why does she move into a florida by the
way i mean
yeah oh yeah we go back and forth we're
uh uh her flight is a long flight we're
trying to get a date for her to get on
the podcast the next time she's in crazy
idea crazy idea we go to hawaii
flight but what is what is it if you
want to send me to hawaii
i'll see you guys special correspondent
dave
you guys go to hawaii and you interview
tulsi that'd be great what does she say
when you question her about being a
democrat i don't want to say anything
that we've talked about privately but
you know i i think i can say it's
obvious from her public statements that
she's hanging on by a thread that that
she's trying to hold a position that i
think is an honorable position that
they're not all insane and that there
could be a decent liberal left
i think that's what you're trying to say
you are or at least were
and it just and trust me i'm a guy that
my first book was all it was a defense
of liberalism
it's just it doesn't work anymore trump
you know i kept making the argument and
trust me it was not easy to come out as
a trump supporter or it's just a stupid
statement a trump supporter i was i
voted for trump yes i voted for a guy
who was president um i was making the
argument for a long time that trump
actually was defending liberalism and
conservatism it was obvious how he was
defending conservatism he believed in
the free market he was appointing
conservative judges things like that
obviously but he was defending
liberalism because look the guy
he had a freaking rainbow uh
flag on stage with him before he was
president he was actually defending
equality remember that moment at the
state of the union i'm sure you guys saw
it when he talked about all
uh was it all-time low black and
hispanic unemployment and the entire
congressional black caucus sat there
like this and didn't applaud
he did not care about any of those
things he was actually trying to save
both you're never going to get a more
liberal conservative re that's really
the truth he doesn't care remember his
answer on the trans bathroom thing they
said to him uh what do you think about
trans bathrooms when that was a big
thing he goes i'm a builder if you tell
me i could build a hotel with one
bathroom you know how much i'm gonna
save i would freaking love to do that if
you enjoyed this short clip click over
here to watch another short clip and if
you want to watch the entire episode the
entire podcast click here
[Music]